increasingly the Black Sea is becoming
part of the battlefield in the war
between Russia and Ukraine video from a
naval drone released by Ukraine's Armed
Forces shows the attack on the Russian
zik oil tanker which damaged its engine
room on Friday a Russian warship was
targeted at the novocorosis naval base
in southern Russia while this time a
civilian ship was hit Ukraine says the
attack was justified the head of its
Security Services was quoted as saying
such special operations are conducted in
the territorial Waters of Ukraine and
are completely legal if the Russians
wanted to stop they should use the only
option for this to leave the territorial
Waters of Ukraine and or land
the attacks on the Black Sea come after
Russia pulled out of the U.N brokered
grain deal that protected Ukrainian
grain exports in the past year since
then Russia has targeted Ukrainian grain
facilities and damaged tens of thousands
of tons of grain the attacks on the
Black Sea come at a time when Ukraine
hopes to get a support for its peace
plan at a summit on the way in Saudi
Arabia with Nations attending that so
far have stayed neutral like China India
and Brazil Ukraine wants to build a much
larger International Coalition
China missed the peace Summit in
Copenhagen in June this time its special
Envoy Lee we will take part Russia has
not been invited it is very important
that the world understands that everyone
will benefit from a just and fair end to
Russian aggression liberating Ukrainian
land from occupies means restoring the
full respect of international law and
the U.N Charter zelensky hopes the talks
in Jeddah will lead to a Global Peace
Summit later this year stepfather Al
Jazeera Kiev